Nos dicen que,
observa el plano coordenado de arriba...
yo lo puse aquí a un lado...
identifica un sistema de dos rectas
que tiene una única solución.
Entonces identifica un sistema de dos rectas
que no tiene solución...
Hagamos la primera parte,
un sistema con una única solución...
única solución...
nos piden identificar un sistema,
pero podemos ver aquí va a haber dos sistemas
que tienen una única solución.
Cuando hablamos de una única solución,
estamos hablando de un único punto de coordenadas
"x", "y", que satisface
ambas ecuaciones del sistema.
Así es que cuando vemos a los puntos de intersección,
este punto de aquí satisface la ecuación
de esta recta roja,
la ecuación "y" igual a "0.1x" más 1
y también se encuentra sobre esta línea azul,
se encuentra sobre la gráfica
que representa la ecuación "y" igual a "4x" más 10,
así que este punto de aquí representa la solución al sistema formado por estas dos ecuaciones,
esto también lo podemos ver como el punto "x", "y",
que cumple con ambas restricciones.
Así es que un sistema que tiene una única
solución, es el que consta de la ecuación
"y" igual a "0.1x" más 1 y la ecuación representada
por esta recta azul, que es la ecuación
"y" igual a "4x" más 10.
Ahora, solo nos pidieron identificar a un
sistema de dos rectas que tenga una única solución,
lo cual ya hemos hecho,
pero para que lo veas también
hay otro sistema que cumple con eso,
así es que este es un sistema
y otro sistema es el formado por esta recta
verde y esta recta roja,
este punto de intersección que tenemos aquí,
de nueva cuenta representa el valor de "x" y "y",
que cumple tanto con la ecuación de esta recta roja
que es "y" igual a ".1x" más 1,
"y" igual a "0.1x" más 1,
al mismo tiempo que cumple con la ecuación
representada por esta recta verde,
que es la ecuación "y"igual a "4x" menos 6,
así es que si ves este sistema,
tiene una única solución,
pues las rectas que lo representan
tienen un único punto de intersección,
al igual que este sistema de aquí abajo
que tiene un único punto de intersección.
Ahora, la segunda parte del problema nos pide,
identifica un sistema de dos rectas que no
tiene solución,
así es que un sistema que no tenga solución...
sin solución...
Ahora, para que un sistema no tenga solución
significa que las dos restricciones no se traslapan,
que no existen valores que cumplan
con las dos ecuaciones,
no hay una pareja de valores "x" y "y"
que sea común a las dos rectas
y eso es lo que pasa
con estas dos rectas paralelas,
la recta azul y la recta verde,
dado que nunca se intersectan,
no existe un punto coordenado que
cumpla con las dos ecuaciones,
no existe una pareja "x" y "y"
que cumpla con ambas.
Así es que la respuesta a la segunda parte
es el sistema conformado por la recta
"y" igual a "4x" más 10
y la recta "y" igual a "4x" menos 6.
Y observa, las dos rectas tienen exactamente,
exactamente la misma pendiente,
son rectas distintas,
pues tienen ordenada al origen diferente,
así es que nunca se intersectan
y por eso el sistema no tiene solución.